في السعودية ، الرغبة في العثور على أشخاص يتحدثون
عن دونالد ترامب ، فمن الأفضل أن أبدأ
خارج مقهى هارلي ديفيدسون ، هل يمكنني أن
أطرح عليك سؤالاً ،
نعم تفضل ، تعرف من هو هذا الرجل الذي
أعرفه ولكني لا أريد أن أذكر
اسمه دونالد  لا بأس في ترامب
بمجرد أن أريتك هذا ،
فأنت تعرف من هو دونالد ترامب ،
أحب هذا البرنامج ، لقد أعجبك برنامجه ،
نعم مرة أخرى في البرنامج جيدًا ، أنت تعرف من
هو هذا الرجل حقًا ، فأنا لا أعرف أنك
لا تعرف ذلك  أعرف أن دونالد ترامب سيصبح
رئيسًا جيدًا هل تعتقد أنك
سمعت عنه نعم كلينتون دونالد ترامب
من ستختاره جيدًا أعتقد أن
الرجل الكوبي سرقك ماركو روبيو
أفعل أوه ، هل
تعرف من هو هذا الرجل أعرف نعم أوه نعم
لا أريد التحدث عنه ، أرجوك
ما اسمه سيدي دونالد ترامب ثم
اعتقدت أن دونالد ترامب أعتقد أنه
سيفعل شيئًا جيدًا لا أعرف أنني
لست متأكدًا مما ستفعله
بالمسلمين أو بالرجل  عدم
الخروج لعدم السماح للمسلمين بالقدوم إلى
أمريكا ، أعني أن هذا غبي جدًا
ألا نسمح للناس استنادًا إلى كتاب
قرأوه أو دينهم الذي يؤمنون به في
أي شخص آخر أن يتعرفوا على دونالد ترامب ، لا لا ،
لا ، أنت تعرف من لم
يكن بوش  لا لا لا ، لم أحضر يوم الخميس
للمرة الأولى بعض الطرق لمواصلة
الحملة الانتخابية هنا يبدو أن آي
سي روبرتسون سي إن إن الرياض المملكة العربية السعودية